so one one thing um with regard to
this this particular pyramid scheme
um that makes use of this intransigent
intransigent minority in teleb's words
to make a tiny minority position appear
to be the majority
is that um you know many pyramid schemes
are are basically opt-in
you get approached and there's this
external motivator
and external motivators tend to be
either carrot or stick and this is part
of why external motivation is not nearly
as effective
or honorable as internal motivation but
external motivators tend to be
characteristic
and a typical pyramid scheme is using uh
the carrot of your own greed
right your own greed for wealth and and
therefore you know when it's carrot it
can be opt-in you like come come to the
carrot
but these this one here it seems to be
opt out
and it's using the stick it's using fear
it's using the fear of being hurt if you
don't succumb
if you don't get in line as the way that
it motivates people to join
and it's not even it there's an opt-out
component but um
are we opted out i mean it seems to me
we've got live stream after live stream
talking about the fact that we are not
on board with this thing that we cannot
affect
the fact that the mayor slash police
commissioner of our city
has um decided not to enforce the law
locally and the new york times has
decided to portray
federal action to enforce the law around
federal buildings
as a fascist incursion so we are being
set
up right so as much as we would like to
opt out we can opt out of
the narrow thing of participating in
spreading the ponzi scheme
but we cannot opt out of its
consequences they have opted everybody
in and so
what what i think needs to be understood
is nobody has any idea what fraction
of the population of seattle actually
organically believes
that abolishing the police and
abolishing prisons would be a good idea
it's not a large percentage it's not a
large percentage
of black people it's not a large
percentage of anything
what it is is contagious and so
the the question is not how many people
will
say black lives matter therefore
these downstream consequences because
those people
are rationalizing their own
participation in a ponzi scheme
right and you can actually see this in
the history of ponzi schemes
the initial ponzi scheme involves stamps
um
then there was a bunch of pyramid
schemes you and i remember as kids
that there was this pond this uh pyramid
scheme
moment where the fbi started busting
pyramid schemes
and you know it was like the late 70s
early 80s yeah i think it was 70s it was
and there was all of this footage of
like these uh you know
rooms full of card tables people had
rented these spaces for their
for their uh um pyramid schemes
and people were marched out in handcuffs
and all of this stuff and then there was
this next phase which was the
multi-level
marketing version where instead of just
having a pure pyramid scheme you
pretended it was about a product
right and so anyway this is the house of
cards has something inside of it right
you're selling some object rather than
selling an
opportunity to participate in a pyramid
scheme right so that you can rationalize
that this is really about knives or
water filters or whatever the hell
was because products yeah right beauty
products um
so now we're in a new phase and that's
kind of the point here is the new phase
is there's no product there is a
message that is being carried forward
and that message is structured
so everybody can sign on right
if you can't sign on to black lives
matter there's something wrong with you
and i actually agree with that
at the slogan level yeah black lives are
undervalued
anybody should be able to sign on to
that but having signed on to it
what have you dragged in with you you've
dragged in all of these nonsense
proposals these civilization ending
proposals
right which you can disavow you can say
oh no but you know i got attacked on
twitter
you know nobody is saying abolish the
police
really i can read in the new york times
right it's right there
but you can tell yourself what abolish
the police means is
defund which means reduce the
militarization yadda yadda all of the
rationalizations so but you see
on on the official black lives website
which is the one
thing that they have given to uh you
know those of us who would like to make
them
accountable for what they're doing right
um you
you see as we've talked about in past
livestreams them going after the nuclear
family them
conflating trans black lives with all
black lives and right you know rising in
the ranks
um trans lives you know over over all
sorts of other lives
uh you see official black lives matter
accounts going after
israel so you know in what way is
anti-semitism
about black lives matter and what in
what way are trans lives about black
lives matter in what way is the nuclear
family
an attack on black lives matter i mean
really i mean that's that's the most
obvious one to say what are you guys
doing right
yeah it's preposterous but okay let's
go to the next phase so you've got
absolute nonsense arguments
you've got policy which is moving at an
incredible rate
like port seattle is now playing
with the most dangerous moves based on
the idea that there is public outcry
demanding these things when that public
outcry is itself
based in part on fear and in part on a
pyramid scheme
and there's no way i mean we are
literally not supposed to be making
policy on the basis
of people being violent in the street
right right
and yet that's what we're about to do
and it it um
it looks very much like uh to leb's
point about the tiniest minority being
able to drive
policy which is absolutely undemocratic
[Music]